state after state after state in the
united states is getting into the
bitcoin game they are trying to use
taxes to incentivize bitcoiners and
bitcoin miners to move to their
jurisdictions what exactly am i talking
about well the state of illinois now is
trying to use that tax incentive to get
bitcoin miners to move to the state but
they're not actually creating brand new
legislation instead what they're trying
to do is take a data center tax
incentive that was created back in 2019
and have it extend out to also include
bitcoin miners now there's a couple of
things that you'll have to do to be able
to actually get this tax incentive first
you'd have to invest at least 250
million dollars within the state you
have to create at least 20 jobs and
you'll have to have achieved carbon
neutral status or green building
certification now all of the little
nuances and details actually don't even
matter it's just the fact that there's
people on both sides of the aisle
republicans and democrats that want to
see this happen whether we're talking
about illinois or florida or kentucky or
arizona or texas maybe even washington
state and everywhere in between all of
these states realize that the future of
job creation of economic prosperity end
of tax revenue comes from the crypto
industry they want bitcoiners they want
bitcoin miners they want cryptocurrency
enthusiasts all to move to their
jurisdiction using taxes as an incentive
rather than a stick ends up being a
pretty good strategy my guess is that
they'll get this done you'll get some
bitcoin miners that move to the state
that actually go ahead and benefit from
this tax incentive and it's a net
positive for the state and for the
miners taxation can be a carrot or a
stick and it's great to see politicians
around the country starting to realize
if you want bitcoiners if you want
bitcoin miners you're gonna have to
compete what can you offer them because
they have a lot to offer you and
ultimately the states that understand
this the states that embrace this and
the states that get out ahead of it
they're the ones who are gonna win over
the long run hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time